(acclamations)
- José Antonio Kast est
le vainqueur-surprise
du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle chilienne,
avec 28 % des voix. Admirateur
de Donald Trump et de Jair
Bolsonaro, et de leurs méthodes
polarisantes de campagne, il est
l'expression d'une extrême-
droite qu'on pensait démodée
depuis la dictature
d'Augusto Pinochet.
FERNANDO GARABITO, journaliste
- C'est une droite très
pinochetiste. D'ailleurs, José
Antonio Kast, le candidat de
l'extrême droite chilienne, il
s'est affiché toute sa vie comme
un pinochetiste. Il a dit lui-
même que Pinochet, s'il était
vivant, il voterait pour lui.
- Avec 26 % au premier tour,
en face, un jeune candidat de la
gauche, Gabriel Boric, 35 ans,
ex-leader étudiant de la grande
révolte de 2011, qui porte
les espoirs des Chiliens qui
descendent dans la rue depuis
deux ans pour exiger des
réformes sociales : retraites,
santé, éducation.
- Pas mal de Chiliens sont
inquiets, d'un bord et de
l'autre. Il y a beaucoup
de peur, c'est certain,
ici au Chili... au Québec.
- Les Chiliens du Qu
voté au premier tour à 70 % pour
le candidat de la gauche, de qui
va dépendre le vote des jeunes.
- Si le Chili a explosé, a eu
une explosion  i i i i il y a
deux ans, avec un gouvernement
de Pinera, de droite, sans
doute, mais pas à l'extrême
de droite de José Antonio Kast,
on peuererererer ce qui pourrait
se passer avec un gouvernement
aussi décomplexé comme celui
de José Antonio Kast.
(brouhaha de cris)
- Après la révolte populaire
de 2019, les Chiliens ont élu
une assemblée constituante,
qui doit rédiger une nouvelle
constitution qui devrait effacer
les aspects contestés de celle
héritée de l'ère Pinochet.
Le sort de cette constitution,
qui doit être approuvée par
référendum, probablement
l'an prochain, dépend
de l'élection de dim
- Parce que d'un côté, on a
Gabriel Boriaiaiaiaiaiaiment,
représente le oui à la nouvelle
constitution, représente toute
cette envie de changement.
Et de l'autre côté, on a José
Antoququququququi, finalement,
a été toujours sur le camp
du non, de rejeter d'emblée
tout changement, de dire que
changer la constitution, c'est :
on change rien.
- Une élection clé, dont va
dépendre l'avenir d'un pays
en proie à des doutes profonds
sur lui-même.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Montréa